le 19/20 continuer voici le rappel des
titres certains dirigeants actuels en
roumanie avait préparé la révolution
plusieurs mois al avance de nouveaux
documents dans cette émission sur les
réunions du conseil du front de salut
national
la marée noire au maroc suite c'est le
pétrolier iranien est remorquée tout
doucement vers le large
des cargaisons elle ne se trouve qu'à 20
km des côtes
la pollution atmosphérique en région
lyonnaise l'alertent préventif déclenché
le 29 décembre vient seulement d'être
levée enfin cyclisme avec un gros plan
sur le contrat mirifique signé il ya
quatre mois entre greg lemon et le
groupe z ce dernier cherche toujours un
partenaire financier le front de salut
national a bien été créé en roumanie
quelques mois avant la chute de nicolae
ceaucescu cette affirmation du général
militaru prononcé au cours d'une réunion
du nouveau pouvoir le 22 décembre vous
l'avez entendu hier soir sur notre
antenne
un document réalisé par un cameraman
amateur document qui n'a subi aucun
trucage et qui est parfaitement
authentique comme l'a confirmé la fp à
bucarest cet après midi ce document nous
avons choisi de le rediffuser retour à
bucarest c'était le 22 décembre au
palais présidentiel la confusion est
totale
yannick ce coupé très romane viennent de
s'adresser à la foule
ils veulent maintenant rédiger le
premier communiqué du front de salut
national
à l'intérieur du palais de nombreuses
personnes accusées y ait secoué son
groupe de vouloir récupérer le mouvement
pour calmer les esprits lyonniais secoue
accepte qu'une caméra puisse filmer
cette première séance de travail à ce
moment là la tension est extrême
on tire dans les sous-sols du palais ses
futurs membres du gouvernement vont
complètement oublier la caméra
mais je ne sais pas comment il fera pour
entrer ses salades parce que la gêne y
avoir une assise ne peut pas venir alors
nous sommes foutus
mais ici c'est à moi
il connaît certaines choses il sait pas
rentrer avec le camarade stanley déjà
les premiers propos tenus mystérieux
jette un certain trouble
mais quelques minutes plus tard une
discussion entre lyonniais spook futur
président du front du sel nationale
pétri romane futur premier ministre et
le général luis lietaer futur ministre
de la défense cette discussion révèle
que la création du front de salut
national ne relevait surtout pas de
l'improvisation salue ce n'est pas bien
quand même du coup d'état democracy now
miami et secours excusez moi mais la
démocratie on a déjà parlé un peu
partout dans le monde m mais ça lui
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
moi quand j'ai parlé à la télévision
j'avais dit le fond d'unité populaire et
général militare le front de salut
national fonctionne depuis six mois ce
document est donc une preuve formelle
le front de salut national n'a pas été
créée le 22 décembre 89
il existait donc depuis un certain temps
en roumanie un groupe de personnes à
l'intérieur et à l'extérieur de la
l'état qui prépare l après ceausescu
témoin cette apparition incroyable en
pleine réunion d'un haut responsable de
la securitate art délai à nous chefs de
la défense brigade anti-terroriste
dépendant de la division sac la plus
redoutable un coup d'état aurait même
été initialement prévu le 24 décembre
mais les événements de timisoara ont
obligé le front de salut national a
précipité les choses
ce comité clandestins ya encore deux
semaines s'est donc retrouvé plus tôt
que prévu à la tête de la roumanie
le premier ministre roumain petre romane
était notre invitée hier soir en direct
de bucarest sans aucune volonté de
polémique nous souhaitions lui poser
plusieurs questions soulevées par la
révélation de ce document hier monsieur
romane a réaffirmé le caractère spontané
de la révolution dans son pays
jean-françois gringoire et l'ensemble de
nos envoyés spéciaux et était dans les
locaux de la télévision roumaine
à l'issue de l'émission il nous envoyait
également un nouveau document
le premier ministre peut être romane
équipements la télé romaine très en
colère la chaîne nationale vient de
diffuser en direct le 19/20 du 1er
janvier toute la population roumaine a
pu voir prendre une heure d'autres
journal mais surtout elle a découvert
avec stupéfaction son premier ministre
petr romane
le président du comité de salut national
lyonniais secoue et d'autres
responsables roumains réuni pour la
première réunion du comité des images
prises avec le consentement de yoni et
ce coût au siège du comité central place
de la république
très embarrassé monsieur romane a tenté
de mettre en doute l'authenticité du
document l'heure la date et le lieu
traduction nous sommes arrivés deux
minutes trop tard juste après le départ
de l'hélicoptère sur la place port
là haut sur le toit peut-être romane
parle de la chute de ceausescu
c'était le vendredi 22 décembre 1989
vers 14h au palais où cette réunion a eu
lieu
quatre ans plus tard ce jour là le
président y ait ce point proche de
gorbatchev aura eu pour premier souci
d'informer moscou sur la situation en
roumanie
comment j'ai contacté l'ambassade diviès
poupaud qu'il vise à moscou qui nous
sommes et ce que nous voulons
alors fr3 notre chaîne ne peut que
regretter bien sûr la décision du
directeur de la télévision roumaine de
diffuser notre journal hier soir dans
son pays sans en avertir sans en avoir
averti donc le premier ministre petr
romain alors juge douch ait ces
documents appelle plusieurs commentaires
le premier nos documents sont
irréfutables chacun le sait aujourd'hui
le conseil du front de salut national
existaient bien avant la révolution de
décembre il n'y a pas lieu de polémiquer
effectivement l'existence du front du
salut national était et est connu il
rassemblait des membres du parti
communiste roumain aussi lâche hostiles
à ceausescu et il s'est fait connaître
en septembre dernier exactement sous la
forme d'un appel que le monde d'ailleurs
du 26 octobre a largement analysés on
voit ce document du du monde c'était
quelques semaines avant le 14e congrès
du parti communiste roumain le front du
salut national appelait alors les
délégués au futur congrès à démettre
ceausescu de ses fonctions et je cite le
texte c'est peut-être là estimé le front
du salut national la dernière occasion
d'éviter un conflit social majeur
d'éviter un bain de sang auquel conduit
presque toujours le désespoir
je signale que ce document reprenait
dans ses grandes lignes une lettre
ouverte signée par six anciens
dirigeants roumains parmi lesquels
manescu s'il vous brouillonne qui sont
actuellement aux conseils du chemin du
salut national du conseil qui a été
constituée vendredi dernier alors
comment expliquez-vous maintenant la
colère du premier ministre petr romani
hier soir sur la trentaine
alors là deux explications je comprends
que le premier ministre soit mal à
l'aise on nous dit que tout a été
spontanée or
peut-être romane qui a participé aux
journées du 21 et 22 décembre se
retrouve dans l'après midi 22 décembre
propulsé sur le balcon du palais de la
république par les étudiants et il a un
mot il dit il faut appeler il faut
appeler il y ait ce coup pensé le même
iliescu qui va on l'a vu dans le
document imposer le nom de front du
salut national
alors que petro man aurait préféré front
d'unité populaire
ça c'est la première raison la deuxième
c'est que si vous voulez pas trop
rappeler la filiation entre front du
salut national d'origine et communiste
roumain alors que le pouvoir cherche à
se démarquer de l'ancien pc romain
basset compromettre les chances des gens
qui vont se présenter sous la bannière
du front du ciel national pour les
élections dans quatre mois merci j'ai
eus nous passons maintenant à l'ensemble
de l'actualité du jour ou à l'étranger
toujours la marée noire se rapproche des
côtes marocaines tandis que le pétrolier
iranien continue de perdre c'est
cargaison au rythme maintenant de 2
tonnes à l'heure et près de 300 km de
côtes sont menacées par cet immense
nappe de pétrole qui n'est plus qu'à une
vingtaine de kilomètres du littoral
tout dépendra maintenant des conditions
climatiques de la vitesse des vents et
des courants
reportage de notre envoyé spécial
isabelle meugle 70 mille tonnes de
pétrole brut déversé dans la mer
les noirs est immense les moyens de
lutter contre elle encore dérisoire
trois hélicoptères de surveillance si
petit avion militaire chargé de répandre
des produits détergents
nous avons constaté ce matin c'est tout
ce dont dispose un des trois centres de
crise du pays un poste de commandement
installé à sa fille à près de 400 km au
sud de rabat proche de la zone polluée
face à la catastrophe écologique qui se
profile le maroc est démuni dépendant
des pays étrangers
à l'heure actuelle une seule mesure
concrète n'a été prise à oualidia le
port le plus menacées par la marée noire
on peut s'étonner si la marée noire
arrive les 3 400 familles qui fit de la
pêche ne pourront plus travailler donc
plus se nourrir
si la pollution arrive vraiment jusqu'à
nos parcs à huîtres en plus il n'y a
plus d'espoir d'une semaine 18 heures
arrivée sur place
avant-hier une équipe de spécialistes
britanniques est en train d'installer un
barrage flottant à l'entrée le lag
lagune de oualidia le but protéger les
parcs à huîtres une des plus grandes
réserves du maroc
notre job c'est des décisions ils ont
besoin de lui
alors on leur montre comment installer
ces barrages notre à fond
la marée noire progresse actuellement de
4 km par jour
elle arrivera bientôt sur les 280 km de
côtes marocaines à oualidia au moins on
pourra en partie limité les dégâts
l'actualité internationale en bref voici
maintenant les télégrammes de l'étranger
préparer commentait ce soir par
marie-odile pas niaise
visite éclair en rda et rfa du nouveau
président tchécoslovaque vaclav havel le
premier déplacement en tant que chef
d'état mais aussi le premier voyage hors
des frontières nationales depuis plus de
20 ans pour cet ancien dissident
compromis en israël ezer weizman reste
au gouvernement mais est exclu du
cabinet restreint de ministres
travaillistes de la science accusé de
contact avec l'ol fait avait été limogé
il ya deux jours par le premier mistral
famille
al'annonce de cette décision le parti
travailliste avait menacé de rompre la
coalition au pouvoir
les états unis et le vatican envoient
des renforts pour sortir de l'impasse
les négociations sur le sort du général
noriega réfugié depuis dix jours à la
nonciature de panama on attend sur place
le numéro deux de la diplomatie
américaine alors que depuis hier les
huit sièges
c'est celle du vatican tente de
convaincre noriega de quitter
volontairement la nonciature attentat à
la voiture piégée à belfast un chauffeur
de taxi a été tué sa fille blessée
l'irak l'armée révolutionnaire
irlandaise a revendiqué cette action
en france la pollution atmosphérique en
région lyonnaise l'alertent préventif
déclenché depuis vendredi dernier vient
tout juste d'être levés mais les
entreprises polluantes reste tenue de
diminuer leurs émissions en dioxyde de
soufre à où les conditions climatiques
sont à l'origine de cette alerte à la
pollution la plus longue jamais
enregistrée à lyon précisément c'est
l'anticyclone qui empêche l'air polluée
de s'échapper de lyon monique le prince
responsable de cette alerte exceptionnel
l'anticyclone présent actuellement sur
la région rhône alpes
les hautes pressions provoqué
l'immobilité des masses d'air et les
brumes se sont comportés comme un
couvercle hermétique emprisonnant l'air
pollué depuis le 29 décembre 17
entreprises parmi lesquelles elle frôle
poulain cateau edf et les chaufferies
ont réduit leurs activités ou utiliser
des carburants - producteurs de dioxyde
de soufre si la situation s'était
prolongée il aurait fallu agir aussi sur
la circulation automobile
ce soir le vent du nord souffle sur la
région et la météo prévoit pour demain
un vent de sud ceci explique la décision
prise à 18h30 de lever l'alertent
d'autant que les 90 capteurs de la
région lyonnaise était depuis ce matin
proches ou en dessous du seuil critique
voici à présent le tour de france de
l'actualité avec les images des 25
stations d'a3 et les commentaires de se
finir
opération escargot autour de caen et du
mans aujourd'hui
depuis 6h30 ce matin les routiers en
colère laisse passer les voitures au
compte gouttes et provoquent
d'importants bouchons
les transporteurs routiers réclame des
mesures d'urgence pour elles et leurs
professions notamment des aménagements
fiscaux et une amélioration de la
sécurité routière réveillon de toutes
les violences à strasbourg le quartier
de la meinau a été victime des casteurs
de la saint sylvestre
une quinzaine de vitrines ont été
brisées des abribus incendié des cabines
téléphoniques éventrée depuis quelques
années le quartier de la meinau est
coutumier de ce genre de vandalisme
une pétition circule en ce moment pour
qu'une permanence du commissariat soit
assurée 24 heures sur 24
casseurs du nouvel an suite à beaune une
discothèque a été complètement saccagée
durant la nuit de la saint sylvestre
les dégâts sont estimés à près de 2
millions de francs à l'origine de cette
folie destructrice
une centaine de jeunes qui avaient été
refoulés à l'entrée du night club
le groupe s'en est pris au directeur de
l'établissement ainsi qu'à un inspecteur
de police venu le protéger les
directeurs de la discothèque a porté
plainte
et puis il ya aussi ce qui fait le
nouvel an de manière plus pacifique
on les appelle les pingouins
traditionnellement ils se baignent sur
la plage d'étretat le premier jour de
l'année
hier l'eau était à 7 degrés jugement
leading l'argent dans le sport le
contrat du siècle en cyclisme celui de
l'américain greg lemond champion du
monde en titre ce contrat de 30 2
millions de francs pour ce quelques
problèmes à celui qui l'a signé et bien
oui à ce jour roger zannier le patron du
groupe z n'a toujours pas trouvé de
partenaires financiers alors que quatre
mois viennent de s'écouler question le
contrat du siècle bathilde ll
aujourd'hui
réponse avec régis gorille pour s'offrir
le portrait de greg lemond sur ce carton
de voeux le patron de z a dû mettre le
paquet 32 millions de francs ont pris le
contrat le plus élevé jamais signé par
un coureur cycliste a conduit
l'entreprise de saint chamond a doublé
son budget courses pour l'alimenter le
groupe z a bien trouvé une astuce majoré
d'un franc chaque produit vendu en
magasin une contribution de la clientèle
versée directement à greg lemon et que
devait compléter la participation d'un
autre sponsor mais quatre mois après la
signature de ce contrat
le pdg de zen n'a pas encore trouvé ce
partenaire idéal si on trouve un
partenaire avec nous ou on est encore en
discussion d'ailleurs avec un partenaire
bah tant mieux ça nous permettrait de
faire plus de publicité traditionnelle
si on n'en trouve pas par contre je
préfère est tout seul sur le maillot kaw
5 ans ou plus personne ne lit rien du
tout roger zannier et irrité quand on
lui demande si son entreprise est assez
solide pour financer seules sept équipes
il est vrai qu'avec le rachat de kickers
et récemment de du gui le groupe z
devrait atteindre un chiffre d'affaires
de 1 milliard de francs cette année les
sportifs eux n'ont plus guère le droit à
la défaillance
l'objectif fixé à greg lemond cette
saison est à la hauteur de
l'investissement publicitaire remporter
le tour de france le championnat du
monde et la coupe du monde sans doute la
rançon de la gloire
pour terminer ce journal un dernier
hommage à la liberté s'élèverait dans le
monde entier à l'occasion du
bicentenaire de la révolution française
plus tarder voici l'image symbole de ce
bicentenaire symbole pour les pays
étrangers cela va vous surprendre jean
pas girouard ils ne se sont pas
consultés et personne ne les y a incité
pourtant les journaux du monde entier
ont choisi dans un bel ensemble une
seule et même image pour illustrer la
france et le bicentenaire de sa
révolution
les responsables de la maison de la
france l'organisme qui en a évalué
l'impact médiatique ont dû se rendre à
l'évidence la liberté guidant le peuple
de delacroix était partout un choix
étonnant et amusant ce tableau a été
composé en hommage aux journées
révolutionnaires de 1830
mais qu'importe l'essentiel c'est le
symbole et il est parfois diablement
significatif les trucages les
compositions les déformations du tableau
havel les différences d'interprétation
de la révolution entre monde latin et
monde anglo saxon dans ce dessein du
journal argentin la nacion la liberté
guide en filigrane toutes les nations
d'amérique du sud
dans cet autre des simples du sunday
times la liberté tête de maure emmène
avec elle lénine polpot et deng xiaoping
tout est dit pourtant et quelles que
soient les traits qu'on lui donne c'est
au final une image positive
la france apparaît féminine dynamique
engagée dans une cause juste c'est
flatteur mais ne nous l'approprions pas
trop cette année c'est hors de nos
frontières que consciemment ou
inconsciemment d'autres peuples ont
suivi le chemin de delacroix
la liberté souvent meurtrières et me
gohi cheli nouveau bilan du nombre de
victimes de la révolution en roumanie on
vient de l'apprendre
oui un bilan qui nous vient du
secrétaire général de la ligue des
sociétés de la croix rouge
il a estimé aujourd'hui à helsinki que
dix mille personnes avaient trouvé la
mort en roumanie dix mille et non pas 60
mille premiers chiffres avancés et qui
était dû selon le secrétaire général à
la confusion en roumanie lors des
premiers jours de l'insurrection
merci fin de cette édition dans un
instant la météo complète de michel
touré avec une toute petite augmentation
des températures il vous en dira plus
dans un instant
au programme de la soirée sur la 3e
avenue de la dernière séance la machine
à explorer le temps et la guerre des
cerveaux et à 22h50
vous retrouverez philippe dessaint qui
vous présentera soir trois avortements
demain à 19 heures pour une nouvelle
édition du 19 20 excellente soirée à
tous
et